[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's going on you guys I don't know if
you can hear me yet I have no clue I
should probably look up this this stream
deck but don't think I'm going to do
that right now
actually I might do that probably a good
thing I just go ahead and hook it up can
you guys hear me
[Music]
do I sound clear my next question
do I sound clear
[Music]
good so far he's not here yet
so you're gonna have to keep that in
mind I'm doing this by myself right now
I'm waiting for King he still ain't here
yet he'll be here momentarily
[Music]
the stream decks still not working I
don't know why
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you guys have to give me a second I have
to look through this stuff and get some
information if I the straight decks
still won't work you've just got to deal
with a messy looking spoiler cast cuz
what I have to do is ought to manually
switch stuff from the actual OBS itself
so you know they look a little bit low
sloppy but it's only when I switch to
Google Hangouts or etc etc it won't be
like the whole podcast or anything like
that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
still waiting for king while the way you
should be here soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
see if it works well it looks like
everything's good now let's see if it
actually switches back and forth like
it's supposed to
messy with the a-b-c no we ain't showing
that man we're not gonna show that kind
of messiness
[Music]
you know if you want man do you want in
this have you beat the game have you
beat the game market soon I'm not to
update this or something it's like this
stream decks just not work
it's definitely not working I don't know
what's up with that
I can't kick it in the face man I need
it I need it
[Music]
the show starts in four minutes some
assuming Keens gonna pop in really at
the last minute I'd like to know why
this dream decks not working couldn't
stand tall ah yeah I do think Abby was
the most memorable character in the game
it's just it sucks how they built her oh
this is spoiler by the way just in case
if I don't have to say that I shouldn't
have to say that but you know how people
are this is definitely spoiler spoiler
territory I'm gonna have another one of
these intros made for this
[Music]
what's up East Texas it's about East
Texas some neo metal dizzy Nova powers
fall nine lives Dan and you guys know I
butcher name so you know forget your
name butcher you you was born the moment
you came into the IOP cuz you I was
doing this
so that's your warning I'm still
debating if I should do the intro you
guys think I should do the intro just
for ILP sake man to keep it original
well that's not really original I mean
it's original to us so that would make
sense you guys think I should do the
intro I think I should do the intro man
are you used to a I'm gonna do the intro
man I've a mode to the intro for old
times sake man for autopsy
Kings still not presents
everyone every member in there man put
put the uh put the shield down there man
put the shells down that lets get those
chills and let's get those shootings I
don't know how many members is here but
let's get those shields down there
represent and where is king
[Music]
get King about another five minutes then
we're just we're just gonna go live man
we're gonna go live have King joining
the process then I can get my bars off
the kid don't have a whole lot of saying
that he's my ear he can't defend himself
and normally you know we're very strict
on and not really strict but it's like a
playful thing where we do the you know
you gotta have in color you know
obviously if you guys want to really
have a you know topic that will break
down definitely put that in there but I
will periodically throughout the part
throughout this show just going in there
and reading someone with it the chat has
to say cuz these aren't as formal as
IOPS are these are more just you know
first off I'm to respond I'm in charge
of these so there you go
[Music]
[Music]
and I will have to be using my phone for
because I only have one screen right now
because my graphic cards messed up and
I'm scared to hook up multiple screens
to it right now so I'll have to be using
my phone to get the chat you got the
barrier with me on that
[Music]
we've delayed this twice it was my fault
both times you know King was doing the
king of statues the second time but you
know it was definitely my fault my
internet be messed it up now don't know
what's up with it it seems to be going
good now whatever infinity did they
definitely fix some things on it you
know it sucks is when it comes to
Internet you only got like one provider
to max and most of the time the second
one's trash so you never use it and they
know what they doing every provider came
together years ago and decide how
they're gonna equally rob us blind
give it a give three more minutes than
we don't we will rock it without him for
a little bit until he gets in here Kings
excited though man he's definitely gonna
be here I just don't know when
how many here's gonna watch us react to
the Xbox event the 20 the 23rd how many
how many here is gonna watch us live
react to that I'm kind of curious
[Music]
that's what's up you guys you know first
off I want to appreciate every one that
comes through you know we we we me and
Cognito originated this podcast we
wanted this to be something unique
something no one else is doing and
because of you know the generosity of
the our fans have done they've we've
been able to increase the performance
the quality of the channel you know the
intro the you know the green screens
that's being on camera all that came
from you guys and you know I meet
particularly and I know everyone
appreciates it but me particularly I
definitely appreciate everything that
the community does for us oh here's King
oughta give me a second you kind of love
little be glad I didn't come in with my
music
[Music]
all right they they insist on us doing
the intro the the intro for IOP I don't
know why I'm going to mute us so we're
gonna do this intro and we'll be right
back you better be glad I didn't coming
with my normal music
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
what's going on you guys let me go ahead
and turn we'll just go to the the
classic one we don't need that that
extra stuff do we King not not for this
alright so obviously me and King are
here you know if you've been paying
attention to the IOP you know we have
two entirely different perspectives at
torrents of The Last of Us
- well I think it's technically
pronounced Elias was part - isn't it
Last of Us part two so you know we've
been doing these spoiler casts trying to
get everyone you know to our more of our
in depth thoughts because we can only go
and do so much when we do in these
podcasts we don't want to spoil anything
so here we are we're doing another
spoiler cast this time it's with Lord
King David say what's up King what's
going on I don't think that y'all
thought I would be on this side of right
alright so anyway you know so first
thing you know I want to break into is I
want to break into I want to leave the
story for last King because obviously
that's the biggest thing that we'll be
talking about so gonna talk about
character development yeah we'll talk
about character development we'll talk
about you know exactly the characters
they brought into the game what happened
during the game and then we'll talk
about the story as an overall concept so
first off let's let's talk about the new
characters alright so obviously they had
you know their Jacksonville was
definitely one of the big things that
they have in this game they've clearly
built this game around the city
obviously it was uh how many years later
was four years later years later okay
yeah so we got new characters I want to
really hone in on Jesse cuz he's one of
the main characters that comes with
duties he's doing a lot of stuff with
you how did you feel about Jesse well
the way Neil introduces Jesse he
introduces Jesse in a weird type of way
because at first you believe that he's
just like sergeant you know for you know
their little militia and then you
realized
he is the former love interest of Dina I
did like how they kind of like
breadcrumb that like yeah you kind of
get that then they like throw the other
break I'm like you know not only is all
this drama going on but she pregnant you
know continuing with Jesse I felt that
he had a tie to Ellie
like it was it was it was kind of weird
because when Joel talks about Jesse
later on it always makes it seem like
he's trying to hook up with her and I
think Deena was just a byproduct of
Ellie never been interested in Jesse you
know so that's why I think that the
whole relationship when they were done
with it he really didn't care that you
know Ellie had kiss Deena at all because
you know that conversation that they
happening in the beginning mm-hmm and in
their in their walking and you know he's
like y'all get dressed cuz you know you
could be like because she overslept and
because he left the party a little bit
earlier that evening when the
altercation happened and she was dancing
he le was dancing with Deena which is
they have been broken up for a week
Jesse and Deena right at that period of
time right yeah yeah sorry I would I
forgot to pull up my green screen okay
so while Adam gets his green screen
together so you can see his glorious
beard and at that point they had already
been broken up for like a week
when this kiss happened so this leads me
to believe that their relationship
wasn't all that as serious as anybody
was making it out to be so now I'm like
okay with the brick home for Joel later
on in the game making it seem like Jesse
had interest in her and I believe Jesse
did and the fact that he like took Deena
as a side project because
was definitely had interest lies and
other other people I think that was an
interesting thing because it showed why
Jesse shows up later on in the game and
why he decided to disobey orders and it
wasn't for the fact that he disobeyed
orders for Dina I he disobeyed orders
for Elly
you know what I particularly enjoyed
about how they did the character
development in this you know at the very
beginning of the game when you think
you're hunting Tommy and it's really
you're you're right behind Jesse because
that's who you think at first like like
I love how the soldiers interact because
let's be real here a lot of the people
were trained by Tommy and Joel right and
they they're more about you know
guerrilla tactics they're more about
stealth kill move stealth kill still
okay because that's literally how you
played the first game I love when you're
coming up on Tommy and you think it's
Tommy but it's really Jesse they're like
these people don't fight like normal
people like it gives you that hinted
that like Jacksonville teaches its
people in a completely different way
than they would I think you know when we
get on a little bit more in a be here
here shortly
I would have preferred her style of
gameplay to be completely nothing like a
le because she could still do the
stealth stuff but I kind of wanted her
to be more of like you know brute force
guns blazing that's that's how I played
with her I actually played both stealth
like so I did in the in I started to
take on the persona of the characters as
I play with them right so when you
looked at the three different militias
you had Jacksonville you had the wolf's
and you had the scars right and then you
can talk scars definitely fought
completely different than completely
different right because they always
maintained high ground and they always
maintained line-of-sight and they use
visual and audio cues to coordinate
their tax whereas you would say the
wolf's use a verbal loud and aggressive
tactics while Jackson do
used none of those tactics it was
completely stealth mode completely like
ninjas try not to be seen
try to use long-distance combat they
pretty much fought regular people how
they fought they infected yes exactly so
so yeah so what what is your opinion on
Jesse as a character and the development
of the character I like Jesse I think
the only real negative thing I could say
about Jesse and it's I'm really naked on
him I just didn't really like how what
you know spoiler can spoiler obviously
when he got captain like no one even
really acknowledges him after he died
like Deena didn't say anything it's like
when he died that's where his story
ended like now he wasn't mentioned he
wasn't talked about after that no one
brought him up one time that's not true
that's not true you talk about when Dida
said he was he would have made a good
father
no well you know sheshe reverend that
part but the family Jesse's family when
they send the letter over you know two
demons talking about you know to come to
me come to Jacksonville the grandmother
and you know they talked about little JJ
and stuff like that they referenced
Jesse inside the letter but you would
ask two individuals that didn't have a
love interest in Jesse to be honest with
you I think Dena was finding herself and
she is just like a little bit loose use
a little bit of loose cannon so she was
playing on both sides of the fence think
like you know there post-apocalypse
there's probably not a whole lot to look
around for me like three people your age
at that time so you know that happened
with Jesse so when he passed yes she
cared for him because remember didn't
care for him when he showed up with the
hurt injury and he and he actually you
know showed some type of care to her is
you know she's sick what's going on was
she infected as his concern was was she
infected then you know come find out
that she was infected with another
disease but
[Laughter]
that do spoiler cast this is Coco Coco
say hi always likes to be in daddy's bed
all right Coco you have to come down
come down all right that's enough
go go go go play now you know as far as
Jesse well how did you feel about Deena
did you feel like they built her up as a
character to get with Elly right Deena
was for the streets
I think Deena was she could flow either
way
Deena had a nice soul and Deena wanted
that home life type of things you know
all the rat race and stuff like that
Deena wasn't about that
Deena was about you know free love
spirit as you can see with the
altercation that happened and in the
words that she said to Elly as far as
you know you're very dangerous they
should be very afraid of you because you
are the most dangerous person here
because you know they're looking at you
because I'm giving my attention to you
and she understood her sexuality in that
whole moment she knew that she was at
allenham le definitely didn't pick that
up at all I have not even remotely
picked that up like like des that was
pretty much like let's leave pretty much
like you know cuz oh you got also
remember le was writing about her in her
book you know le was loving this girl
from a distance forever for since
they've been there so you know the fact
that that night was happening that
moment was happening that situation was
happening it was mind-blowing to le but
Deena knew the level of her sexuality
that she chose to give it to whoever
whenever and however she wanted to and
she wasn't going to be like constrained
by anybody's views of her so when that
part is going down is blowing Ellie's
mind but Deena knew what she was giving
you know she she really didn't care who
was
watching and what was going on at that
period of time because she's comfortable
in her own sexuality so I felt that her
as a character for Elly's Ellie's always
being restrained
and hidden and Dean is out there and
free I would agree on that you know one
of the the best moments in the game to
me was when it comes to Dina and Ali is
when they're in that subway sewer and
Ellie's mass breaks and Dina literally
about to take off her mask and get her
killed Ali was like no no like she was
fighting her because she thought that
Ellie didn't want her to sacrifice
herself when she's what she already
thinks that you know she thinks that I I
think I'm already dead so I don't want
her to die with it and when she put her
out she's like I'm not coughing I was
like y'all was like that that was a good
character build right there
well she tried to see when Ellie gave
into her confidence it has hard a secret
her biggest secret when she told her
that she was bitten by an infected and
she's immune and she told you chemical
burned it - that was yeah I mean to hide
it
exactly initially put a tattoo on top of
it you know then you've seen the gradual
growth of the tattoo from beginning to
you know from concept to art line to
line to fill in to complete tattoo by
the end of the story
which I thought it was magnificent in
the growth of the character but you saw
that how she was completely comfortable
with her and she gave her a big a secret
and Dima didn't believe what they means
like you know it's immune you die and
when she's breathing and she's noticing
that she's not coughing and she's not
dying then she realizes she was telling
the truth
yeah and that was a crazy part because
you know at that time it was kind of
unclear if anyone knew that she was
immune you know they had a lot of facts
that flashback show and Jo saying that
but they try to keep a lot of
information on the day
low up the toilet came up I'll be right
back okay but you know what it's like I
said you guys like one of the biggest
things I appreciate about this game is
just the immersion in the world
development and you obviously I have my
issues with the story and that is for
here that's for you to understand that's
not for anyone to understand about me to
be honest with you I understand some
people love the story
some people hate the store I'm I'm not I
don't think I hate it but I do think it
was poorly written and it was it made me
not even poorly read maybe the story was
good I just feel like the executor did
it wrong like you take some of those
scenarios and you flip them around and
you you know you put some of the stuff
that at the beginning in the middle had
the same conclusion and I think it would
have been way better so you know I
disagree let's just go ahead and get
into it cuz this is gonna be the biggest
okay let let's take it step by step in
the talk the whole thing okay
Joe dime was the first thing that happen
to you it was awesome it was awesome
okay explain because if you watch The
Last of Us part one you love Joe he was
this a religious Christian man who who
goes the country with this child that's
not his to get her to the fireflies even
though he doesn't believe in them he
believes in this kid and along the way
they see things and he starts to believe
and she's not crackers she's used to
being with Daddy anyway so they get to
the fireflies and you know during this
whole time joel is screwing everybody
over you know in the name of Ellie so
let's not forget that you know Joe was
doing whatever he gots to do for the
love of this kid alright and and I
believe his displaced love because his
kid is dead okay
now let me stop you real quick alright
as far as him screwing people over 100%
of great feeling that now there's a lot
of people on on YouTube and Twitter in
general that don't particularly like the
way that they brought out him you know
his past come that's all this game
really was
his past come back came back and he got
him and then you went back and it's
literally a cycle of hate this literally
wouldn't know Drummond said you know she
hated Jo for years she killed Jill
finally and that Ellie hated her for
years the chief whoa you know obviously
later but hold it but real quick real
quick just just just answer this real
quick question a lot of people don't
like that it was the doctor from the
first one that you killed that was her
father they felt like that character was
it relevant enough to to have all this
happen okay and that is with the genius
lies that's where the genius of mill
Druckman Wow God can we please refrain
to saying that is you have to understand
something that you viewed as
insignificant and minor when you got a
chance to see Abby's growing up she
loved her father her father was how
everything so why wouldn't this weak
child cuz at that point in time when
Abby's growing up she's weak she doesn't
have any muscles on anything like that
she's a nice young girl and her father
is a humanitarian he shows you when he
when he when he saves a zebra he puts
his self out then he goes to see these
animals and he's worrying about the
humanitarian aspect of all of his work
and all of his work has something to do
with saving mankind even at the life of
Ellie and Ellie didn't care that her
life would be forfeit because she was
willing at that point she had already
given that at that point she already
submitted to that point because she
thought her life would mean something
that's where she's upset with Jo but
this insignificant character that you
felt that was insignificant
wasn't because he meant everything to
one person his daughter and all it takes
is one person to feel excruciating loss
you know what
percussions are so that insignificant
character that you killed lies we
percussions is the basis of every karate
movie ever told he killed his master
that student that didn't know kung fu
learn kung fu and came and killed you
this is the basis of every revenge film
somebody that you overlooked as somebody
that you thought was insignificant
turned out to be your demise that minor
thing that she looked over not all the
big guys that that Joel screwed over
they didn't come it was the girl that
was weak that made herself completely
strung cos when they did show Abby for
the first time Abby was like oh no sorts
of [ __ ] daughter and over this time
she grew wif that hate she was like
venom she grew with that hate to extract
this vengeance that she had in her soul
cuz she probably felt that her father
didn't have to die and Joe didn't have
to kill him Joe coulda shot him in the
lake one thing that you know I like how
they show like that world development is
when he killed the doctor it pretty much
like was a it was like a domino effect
yep and what happened is it demoralized
the fireflies so much that they'd
assembled yeah and you know I do like
you know instance it's like that just to
me King okay now we're gonna move away
from you wait let's because if you're
talking about that part right you're
talking about the father and you got to
say Marlene Marlene was the fireflies
head right and you thought that Marlene
would be the person that was holding
everything together when it seems like
everybody that the the people that was
holding the firefighters together that
was giving him hope was Abby's father
all right so we we got a couple things
that's going on in the chat just go
ahead and ask so someone did brought up
a good point you know that anger of her
killing for her father you know that
that's definitely something that makes
sense but someone did say in the chat
that said how do you explain her
Abuelita Nellie live multiple times
after killing all of her friends and
okay don't you think that's a little
inconsistent female character develop
listen let's get to it
right if your single purpose is to get
revenge she was blinded by hate
she didn't care about everybody else
like she cared about our Father
her father was a the only thing that she
had left our beacon remember Abby's a
tragic character but as we as we talk
about that character we're going to get
deeper into her psychosis but the fact
that she only wanted Joe only so member
Laden care if they killed Ellie she
didn't really care at that point in time
because she was focused on Joe remember
it was all in that stopped them from
killing Tommy and stopped them from
killing Ellie I was what about what
about the you know Owen that was someone
that I be extremely cared about Abby put
herself like literally a V almost went
AWOL like she did go AWOL to save her
and Ellie killed him and she didn't she
didn't kill Ellie back so like that
that's that's my thing it's just like
when you have that type of hatred that
time when she when when when she killed
Owen and and whatever okay so okay now
at that point in time when she was going
to go kill Ellie and kill Dana who
stopped him I just feel like her friends
tried to stop her from doing no when
they did no because the person has
stopped her was Yara Yara stopped her at
that point in time remember she had
sacrificed everything the Savior is on
so she's endearing herself and forming
her own little group consisted of Yara
and live I live at that time showed her
how to overcome her fears so they were
growing as a team together and it was
sacrificing yourself to get to save Yara
let me ask you a question that people
did people disagree with me with and
it's fine you know it's is that like one
of the good things about last of us is
they always put the interpretation of
something up to you as the place that I
personally feel like after after her
Abby got her rocks off and she killed
Joe
then she started filming remorse for
killing Joe no I personally feel that's
the reason she helped us call it the two
scars people said all is because she
saved her life like she's been literally
hunting this group for her whole life
almost no for like the past three or
four years she's been hunting them and
now all of a sudden she's just gonna
save two random ones and if you remember
every time they asked her well let me
finish my statement every time they
asked her yo why you helping me she
never answers them because she
subconsciously doesn't want to admit
that's the reason she's doing it like to
me I feel like if it was just because
she saved them that they saved her she
would answer that you guys saved me I
got to return the favor
every time they answer she just walks
around the question she never comes out
formally and says it all right now
partial what you're saying is partial
and is a small part when they saw the
level of hatred and she didn't just kill
Joe all right
she brutally beat him to death while her
friends watched now up until that point
you thought the wolves were heartless
killing machines because of Isaac
because of Isaac's tactics so Isaac's
made them seem larger than what they
were he made them seem inhuman alright
so you felt that these characters
in human you thought they were military
in human unit that just did no that's
not the case
Abbey's blinded by hate
Owen is trying to give some form of
reason
that's why Tommy and Ellie's alive
because of Owen only huh friends got a
chance to see Abby's hate and full
effect and they're trying to figure out
this what's going on here what are we
doing here they all start questioning
but at the same time they all turn their
back on Abby because that's the same
period of time where Owen brokes breaks
up with Abby Abby loses all of her
friends that moment Joel dies so they're
no longer the tight friend group the
only person that sticks around with Abby
is mani
because manis her roommate Sheila we
ain't been to the basement I can't tell
you what that basement looking like you
can go down there but we probably ain't
going down that either see you on your
own if you go down there exactly you
understand so mani lived with her Manny
knows her nightmares and her troubles
she had PTSD when her father's died and
a PTSD manifests itself in Ellie when
she had to watch Joe die and we'll get
to that part of the story a little bit
later but seems to miss categorize that
Abby had full control of the situation
she had no control of the situation she
went completely rogue and found Joe and
Tommy randomly now herein lies the rub
Joel was the instrument of his own
demise at every turn had he did not save
Abby he doesn't die Abby dies at the
hands of the Horde and life goes on but
we wouldn't have a story right no games
so you thought she was so some form of
thankfulness no she was blinded by hate
and one
revenge and she got her revenge all
right so let's let's move this a little
bit over to Joel now that is definitely
one of the biggest key points and
probably my biggest issue with the game
is how they handle Joe's demise now
first off I'm pretty sure I know where
you stand but let's go ahead you are for
how he dot correct I loved it okay now
you explain and then I'll count okay so
the fact that no matter is you know Joel
is out there on patrol and they they
come across somebody fighting for the
life for the Horde and they save her and
he like oh you got a camp me know what
if she's like yeah I can get us out of
here we got I have any campus she sets
him up already she knows because when
she finds out who she has she has to get
into a position of power no she's no do
you think that was a like a little bit
too like what I'm looking for
serendipitous I felt like that was just
to two of like a cop out like it's just
like you so happen to come across the
dude that you're looking for in this
entire region like how you gonna
motivate the store how you gonna bring
the story across because it's also
showing drunk Joel isn't that [ __ ]
that everybody wants him to be you did
everything he did to survive right other
people interpretation of you will never
always be the interpretation that you
want to project right everybody's gonna
have their own take on you and Joe was
at a peace part of his life his
character develop those he was never
gonna grow as a character from the point
that where he was
so let's and I definitely understand
that you know I want to get some of the
the members comments neo Meadows said
Joe dying wasn't my issue I'm with that
move the story forward nothing made me
like Abby so I guess his point was he
didn't mind how they killed Joe but I
guess he minded how they always try to
pull out your heartstrings to like a be
more more with the dog playing do you
see a little bit where he's coming from
with that okay
so let's take it to Abby as a child Abby
is the most tragic character in the game
right and let me tell you Abby doesn't
ever find happiness every time she's
about to find happiness happiness is
ripped away from Abby at every turn
every turn let's go to her father
well he's just five seconds Iron Mike
said why would the in uh the wal F send
all of them out there anyway I don't
think they knew that that was even
happening because if you notice when
they do the flashbacks to what happens
in Seattle Seattle day one on Abby they
never bring that up to their commander
or anything I think they went out there
by themselves yeah okay so when they all
left remember they all took a conscious
effort to leave remember Abby was going
to leave and they all decided to go with
their friend remember their unit at this
time they're all together at this time
remember when they were fighting and
they had made it back from their little
encampment in what some call it went
with her the the pregnant girl went with
her yes and they they're trying to get
back and all that they have this
love/hate there because they were a
tight unit team and they broke up from
that period of time so you had to
understand that they weren't really
listening Isaac they were just there
with Isaac but they all had their own
agendas Owen wants to get out Mel only
wants to do whatever all one wants to do
but she wants to be in the military but
they're no longer around and he kept
debating on himself because of his human
attachments to that area if he should
leave and go look for them or not
mmm who was that human attachment Abby
and now it wasn't Mel Mel is a byproduct
of cuddles alright yeah Mel is a
byproduct of cutoff because when he's
with Abby's were a be draw out her whole
time when she gains these muscles when
she wants to super real quick so we
gotta fight all the super chair from
ever born saga Abby's a tragic and very
interesting character portrayed what she
did to Joe as much as
I tried I was naval I was never able to
empathize with her I I cried for Abby oh
I actually liked a be like by the end of
that show I liked Abby but it was just
like I did feel like they try too much
like I did feel like that like I
understood Abby's motives without them
trying to make me like put her on a
human level like like all you had to do
is revenge story I understand her
motives like you don't have to make me
play with dog with her or have this
moment with though you didn't have to
play with the dog I played with the dog
King you're gonna stop her more so
whereas you felt ah why didn't make me
play with the dog with her I was like oh
man look at her you know but her playing
but the dog was showing lived that she
didn't have to be afraid of the dog the
same way they draw they they drew out
the story with her going across the
bridge going across these high
situations where she was terrified
remember the only time she went up to a
high situation is out of love for Joe I
mean for um Owen when she jumped up when
he was on the carousel and she jumped
down for Arlen because she can get a lot
of things out of love I get to you there
but okay let's wrote back a little bit
to super chats and the members got us a
little bit off track let's let's finish
our our Joel conversation okay look
right my biggest issue is I didn't feel
like they killed Joel like he like he
deserved
I felt like a superstar no it's not even
a superstar okay
not even superstar it was not even
nothing like that I just felt like oh I
like Vegeta I see you on your screen but
anyway that's the size the Floyd you
know I really did not appreciate the way
that it felt like they killed him like
he was a support character like they did
I didn't feel like they they didn't give
him justice in the way his roles were in
the first one a lot of people like to
say okay Joe's been there for five years
Joe's gotten soft Joe's gotten this Joe
has gotten that Joe was a smuggler for a
long time and he never got salt a flight
I don't see him just being there for a
couple years and he starts trust in
people I saw some people in the chat I
saw some people in the chat say
was openly willing to give his name to a
bunch of random strangers today he just
came across what what is your thing with
that do you have any issues with that at
this point in time the character
development of Jo was done joel has
found home right Jo just Joel is here he
brought into the to the whole Jackson
camp here here he brought into that Joel
has his house Joe makes little wood
carvings
Joel plays his guitar Joel took them up
and he takes the best routes to overlook
the city to feel accomplished to feel
like he's he's done running he's done to
be killed the same way well he got
killed very brutally he got done in very
brutally how Abby thought her father was
murdered um and it was very
insignificant because everybody felt
that he already had his screen time
enough of his screen time but I do to me
came just to me I personally feel like
they were more you know at the time we
didn't know Abby was such a big part in
this game we'll get into that a little
bit later but to me I feel like they
were so dead I on switching the
narrative from Joel to Abby not Abby -
Ellie that they didn't care how they
ended Josie where they just wanted to
end it and I have a problem with that
like I do feel like there now can we
agree I don't know if you're gonna gray
on this thing there could have been a
better way of doing this that got the
same results no because you have to give
her PTSD you have to have her watch his
final moments you have to have that
scene that is so impactful that she
comes in on a bloody beat up tore down
Joe Tommy has to watch as well Tommy has
to be there as well
Tommy's his brother Tommy is there these
two individuals are there and I'm pretty
sure that you're gonna get Tommy
story later because there's more to that
on some DLC but for Joel to die like
that in a heap and a bloody mess
they that's neil druckmann genius
that's him showing you we call this
writer genius again I'm gonna tell him
he's a genius because I mean you're
gonna give credit where credit is due
so Iron Mike said to you he's a member
he said you can have all of that but the
lead-up needs to make sense so he was
like the lead up to Joe dying didn't
make sense it was me because II was he
was comfortable at that point right I
don't know that that's a question Iron
Mike to me maximum accent I am I okay I
mean were you comfortable cuz I was I
was comfortable my guard was down my
guard was down alright my guard was
completely down I
I said now there's no way did this girl
is gonna do him dirty yet he saved her
life
so rain forward we actually brought up
when he said should Joe and a be a
squared up with Joe and it would have
Joe's death been more meaningful I don't
I don't agree with that and the reason I
would agree with that is I don't feel
like you need to have Joe fight in a
like in a blaze of glory I don't think
he needs to die how he died was was okay
I just felt like there was no build up
from the beginning of the game I do feel
like they didn't like up until you saw
Joe by the time Joe died it was
literally over in an instant it's like
you saw Joe you ran with Joe Joe was
dead like all right and I do feel like
as a character that went through 15 16
hours in the first one that was a little
bit less of a buildup than I had a story
in the first one but yeah missing the
biggest part him and Ellie wasn't on
good terms
see that's that's that's where you get
all these flashbacks that's when you
started getting a story because Joe's
story didn't end right there let's not
act like he was murdered and he didn't
see him again in a game you saw you
didn't see him again in the game all
right so you saw past versions of the
pen but you don't see him
it was necessary to start telling it
from a member and standpoint you know
how last conversation with Joel before
those murders hit man like because it
couldn't you when you see that happening
at the end of the game and like you know
you see that's Joe and Ellie were about
the reconciled they were about to get
over their differences right sooner or
later both of the next day he dies okay
so this is this is the thing you don't
have the time that you think you have
she always thought she got the time I
think so no regular teenager Dan dances
they could have thrown that in there
before the death oil of their split I
think that was in there perfectly
because they used that as a reason to
why you know what happens at the end
where you know Ellie doesn't kill Abby I
think that was the in singer if it was
like look I've been doing this for me I
hadn't been doing this for Joel Joe
would not have wanted me to kill Abby
Joe wouldn't have wanted me to spend a
second try to revenge his death and
putting my life on the line and I I
believe that it heartfully from what he
example dan any word because of Tommy
yeah and I get that but I feel like she
left because she felt like she had
unfinished business and Tommy kept
bringing it up so she felt like she had
to do I mean did that Tommy guilted her
into leaving because Tommy lost his
relationship mammarra Tommy lost his
relationship with Mary because Tommy got
shot in the head and should have died on
that floor inside that that um that
Playhouse the fact that he was still
alive he had a bad leg he had a wounded
chest he had a hole in his head he was
half the man that he was he lost his
relationship because he became better
and filled with anger and rage and his
relationship with Myra definitely just
went to the left so he's there to kill
pretty much what you're singing haughty
person into going and seeking revenge
and she's suffering from PTSD from
seeing exactly all the stuff that she
did and she never reconciled with Joel
before it happened that's why she'd say
yeah that's probably will get up so what
you're pretty much saying is Tommy
to the point where he lost everything he
lost his brother he lost his his wife he
lost everything in Jacksonville and the
only thing you had on to was that plot
of revenge it he felt like until he did
that he couldn't have anything back
exactly and I get that and I get that
but I do feel like you know Tommy might
have pushed her but she wanted to go
that way anyway it's just Tommy pushed
her out the door to go that way you know
why you know you know the words that
time he used oh now you good
like like you got what you want you good
you know I'm saying like he had what he
had but she said that she was gonna go
get revenge and he went out on her
behalf and he lost everything because of
her so she killed some like how do you
get to live this life my life was fine I
was able to let it go I told you to let
it go you didn't want to let it go and
you went out there now do you benefit
and I lost everything he lost he got
shot in the head his I was down this
shot you know he got shot I'm sure they
are
I'm sure Jackson they'll blame him for
Jesse's death too so exactly it's like
but do you think that it's weird how
Ellie loses Jesse Ellie you know Tommy
was crippled Ellie got her ass beat Abby
almost killed Dana do you think it's
weird that Ellie goes from I want to
kill Abby to I don't want to kill Abby
at all anymore just from those events
like to me I feel like when Jesse dime
because you know obviously they weren't
lovers but I do feel like they had a
connection they had a friendship so I do
feel like that would have that would
have pushed her more towards wanting to
go out grabby she she got the girl she
got the girl and at that time is like
holding your eggs you have your eggs you
all right you know what we went to the
mountaintop we did a hell of a lot and
it's bad but I can come out of this in
some form of fashion I can come on on
the right side of this at some point in
time and she did for a second she did
for a second
second how many times in our lives for a
brief second we can take that breath
when we're happy she took that breath
she was happy she was there then along
comes a spider I just feel like if she
was truly content and truly happy then I
don't think anything if she had the
mentality that I'm good I I have moved
on I've no longer wanting on that
revenge game then I don't think Tommy
could have talked her into it I think
that Dana kept her there but Tommy
pushed her over the edge to wanting to
finish what she started because because
that's the only thing that makes sense
to me yeah well I mean that it doesn't
make sense but he did guilt her into
that point if if me and you go out right
and you say yo yo King I'm gonna go take
care of these dudes and you go out there
and I'm like man I'm not gonna let this
do go alone and then I go out there and
I get tore up
I get tore up and you there's nothing
wrong with you you go back to live your
life and then I come here I'm like you
ask man we gotta finish this job man my
leg oh shut up my head o beat up my body
all talk if you at some point I mean I
guess what we don't know how many times
he's done that he could have done that
multiple times they did say that he's
been there multiple times so I mean I
guess I'll give you that I'll give you
that argument I feel like you know
there's some loopholes there but you
know that's just me you can get it we
had a $5 signature from ever born saga
my biggest issue with the experience
that the story was that they didn't give
us players the decision to let Abby go
or not hold on to that ever born we're
about to get into that boy I do want to
get into that that is gonna be the
pretty much the last thing we do now the
next thing I want to talk about when I
move away from the Jo's death because I
I do understand your point
you know without Jo dying there wouldn't
have been and you know there would have
been a game that was I think it was a
cop-out personally I think it was the
quickest and the most efficient ways
they can do it I think there was better
ways to write that story but to me you
know it's not my place to tell them how
to write their story that's just my
criticism to the story now let's let's
talk about the pacing of the story okay
for the game went you know you had your
prologue where you no joke where I'd be
kill Joe and then you had three days
Seattle one two and three where you
played is Ellie did you have Seattle one
two and three plays Abbey and then you
know they had the last bit where you
fight Abbey as Ellie now first question
I want to ask you is is this the way
that you would have liked which do you
think this part you know how they paced
it with the the Seattle they make you
plays one character than another
character do you think this was smarter
do you think they could have done this
one different nobody ever wants to
switch off people don't like change
right and so for story driven games of
this magnitude because it's a semi-open
world depending on your play style and
your pacing you dictate the pace of the
game I know people that finished it all
a lot faster than I finished it I know
people that still playing the game and
they play at a slower pace pace of the
game but when giving your characters and
they're trying to have you learn these
characters and understand their
motivations the pacing is really totally
up to you
like like you you don't look for
everything in a game like you don't try
to max out every weapon you you know
kind of keen in on your thing you kind
of came in on what's funny yeah happy
you know that the hunting our country
had when you put a scope on that and you
max out that damage scope people out
they couldn't even come close to me yeah
so a lot of people in the chat you know
said that they had a problem with a be
having the better guns III don't
necessarily think a be had the better
guns
I thought Ellie was a better character
in general in combat because Ellie had a
knife and you didn't have to do [ __ ]
with the clickers thank you you do you
do you understand they really are
completely two different characters yeah
if he has the more I'm gonna shoot
people guns and Ellie has the more I'm
going to shoot you if I have to
I'm gonna use this knife and try to take
as many as you as I can exactly
completely a little bit more stealth
when it goes around to it but have you
ever moved the characters around in a
space separately to see how they move we
must wait more on the top part of her
legs and Abby just moves like she's
walking
yeah she's agile like she can move out
of the way of a dodge of a clicker and
stuff like that she's a little bit more
agile than Abby and I think that
reflects that how many time Mike said
got caught in the game Iron Mike says
Abby is Jo and Elliott Ellie so he's
pretty much saying they took the kind of
place no that Joe had I'd agree with
that I think that's actually a pretty
safe place tile that's true but also she
plays true and her guns are true to her
military upbringing you know remember
she comes from the fireflies and then
she goes into the wolves so at that time
she the guns that she's using the stuff
that she's using the combat styles that
she's using she's forming a shiv you
know she's doing these things and I
think you know you know I think they did
that on purpose too first off I think
they wanted to have like an Easter egg
from the first one I remember these
SHIVs I remember making these like I
think what they wanted stuff like that I
do think that you know they wanted their
play styles to be different I personally
felt like you know besides the big
people you could play Abby exactly how
you play Ellie and there's no rural
differences there was a couple enemies
since you didn't have the doesn't the
knife
you couldn't just come up and sneak on
them and I do I will give you that that
that is probably the the way that they
wanted you to shoot them big people
unless you had a shift they didn't want
you to you know walk up on them and
stuff exactly well those dudes is crazy
like what about when the evil and she's
Abby's fighting this big monstrosity of
a juggernaut down the side oh you had no
no weapons
didn't you notice that it's been I was
sitting there fighting this dude because
it was a long fight it was a minutes and
I'm thinking or thinking that that
chicken her kid have been sitting there
for a minute they definitely like God
God got there got their head back in
there their mind back in their head and
I'm like aren't you gonna help me like
this dude is like four times the size of
me you are out of control you know what
King the best parts of the game yeah I
thought Abbey's Abbey's instances of the
game was more thought-out as far as I
don't know it's just as if IIIi really
liked the character so I'm gonna I'm
gonna say that part because I really at
the end of the game I hated Ellie at the
body by the end of the game I wanted her
dead so so so wonder exactly did you
want her dead when you fought her as a
be because I thought that was a really
interesting they way they did that is
where you're a be fighting Ellie and you
see Ellie like you know leaning down
doing her Stella stuff and I'm like I
know how you fight chick I'm not gonna
let you out of my sight which you put a
little bomb yeah I in time I was
sympathizing I would didn't make the
complete turn over to Abby at that point
in time I was caring about Abby at that
point in time when she was trying to get
Ellie or after she shot Jesse in the
face and wanted to hunt him down hunt
her down
I was making my transition because I saw
the selflessness of the character and
she made that one mistake of allowing
revenge to change her heart because the
heart was so beautiful that's the same
heart that I father had in you know
saving zebras and going to the zoo and
she changed as a character and in in
changing as a character she changed how
her friends and everybody viewed her
that Mel said like one of the most
hurtful things to her that she's a up
and she acts up everything around her
and she destroys people around her and
and for someone to hear that you know
and that's not their intent I think that
goes a little bit further in changing
how she interacts with other characters
in the game like as far as live and as
far as Yara and and her willingness to
help because remember at the heart of it
all she's a Firefly
yes yeah she she I thought it was cool
at the end how you know she it looked
like the fireflies are done but she
found one of their outposts and she
found out that they're coming back
together that's when I cried yeah so you
know the biggest issue people have
obviously is you play a lot of this game
is that way as happy and do you think
that people let me ask you a question
your personal opinion do you think
people didn't like playing is Abby
because she was a bad character they
didn't like playing Abby because she
killed Jill they don't want to play
because of how the lead-up to the story
was presented to everyone the lead-up to
the story presented to everyone let's
call a spade a spade you saw Ellie like
tell Joel that she was gonna go do
something and she was walking away from
Joel right so when you saw that you
thought that Joel will be alive so they
gave you all a false sense of security
and they killed really some false a mark
exactly that's what's called ILP talk
that's not the marketing mislead you and
made you upset and then you have Ellie
and Ellie turns out to be this weird old
douche Nova saying something I think you
like he said when a be like Oh Dana and
Ellie live
I was completely invested in her
character when Ellie left her family and
inhaled leave at knifepoint I was done
with Ellie you know why that didn't kind
of seem a little bit out of her
character just know I did it wasn't out
of her character because she's a douche
I just don't feel like how you can go
from having the knife to to Alexis Matt
to letting her live ten minutes later
listen Ellie's a douche
so right okay before you know before we
let's just go ahead and shift to you
know that the ending because that's what
we're talking about right now is in the
ending obviously there was a first off
the fight between Ellie and Abby was
epic I loved it that was probably one of
my favorite times wrenching it was it
was hard for me yeah it was very hard
foul I love that that was good yet cuz
you love at me see you is definitely I
don't want to hit let me ask you a
question since you really really like
Abby when you had Abby's head under that
water and it looked like you really
might kill her I was crying with the
controller in my hand yo I first of all
I let her kill Ellie like 15 times
I let her kill her like $15 daddy killed
Ellie like 15 times the game forced me
to do something that I was completely
uncomfortable with and I seen her and
the choking became a little bit easier
and the bubbles and I'm shaking and
tears coming out of my eyes and I'm like
wow eff is going like the biggest
question is a lot of people have the
issue because I have one of the super
judges came up is from stiched he says
why revenge is OK for Abby but now Ellie
just hold on to that thought for five
seconds stitch I want to go back to the
preview super chat because the kind of
goes hand in hand but wherever boring
saga said my biggest issue at the
experience that this story was they
didn't let us as a player have the
decision to let Abby live or die would
you have preferred that would you prefer
them to you even if one side is caning
on one side it is not I personally feel
like if you're not gonna have two
different games for whatever the next
sequel is you need to have one ending
because it kind of makes no sense to
have two options when you know for a
fact you're only gonna have a bye to one
of them so you know the question I have
to you is you know is it okay for a
revenge plot with a B but why is it not
with Elly because you have been like
kind of hinting that he's a douche that
Elly's a douche and a B you know she's
justified for what she's doing and my
second question is you know should we
have gave them should Naughty Dog have
gave the players the ability to choose
between killing her and not killing her
no that's not you don't give the ability
to choose you force them into that
position of uncomfortable spot you put
them in a position that I was in that it
was completely uncomfortable but III say
this insane that you had to see the
ending that a B everybody lost Joe lost
his life I'd be lost on mussels that's a
loss and more and more I'm going to get
it I have to make light of it right now
because my heart is heavy even it's a
game um
Ellie lost everything she had the girl
of her dreams there they had a baby with
no baby daddy to show up and bother and
they have a farm they had a whole life
and she came back and all stuff was in a
room everything's gone and all her stuff
is in a room you know what really got me
maybe cuz you felt really emotional
comes the stuff of Abbey I thought it
with Ellie like you know you came back
how did you feel and when she liked it I
kind of teared up a little bit what she
would she try to play the guitar and she
couldn't play that you have the tool she
was sitting there and you could tell
like she left that guitar there and they
and you know they didn't show from her
perspective that time
it was like they let she left that anger
with that guitar because at the end of
the day she lost everything and she
can't even play the thing that calms her
down anymore and when when she's walking
in the field and the bone you only see
the top of the guitar I was like damn
well I will give Neil that that
particular shot you got a new I'm not
giving no everything I'm gonna give Neil
everything not happy you gotta give me
everything
how many times did Owen and Abbey sleep
and she had those nightmares she was
tortured absolutely tortured listen why
are we glossing over the sexual
encounter with Abbey and Owen why why do
we just won't pass the most visceral sex
scene that I've seen in a video this
game deserves an r-rating it was pretty
detailed you kind of caught me off guard
to be honest with you I didn't expect it
to be like that boy I thought it was
gonna be the ho-hum known mr. Druckman
genius genius Neil but he went there
with everything you know where we're
glowing over the range of emotions that
this game had you feeling how are you
not gonna feel Fabian got ours off and
then totally dude you got your
priorities mixed up cuz she loves this
guy and she's like you know you better
choose your baby mama you got your
priorities messed up let me go tender my
business even though that part hurt and
you don't think she didn't want to kill
Dino and Deena was on the floor with how
love is dead and the only thing that
stops that is live I just feel like from
a standpoint you know we won't go too
much into that
know that you know there was just
inconsistency when it comes to stuff
like that obviously you feel a different
way and I understand your philosophy
well I think I think I think at the end
of the day King you know what I think
the issue between me and you with this
game is as I thought
Abbie was cool but Ellie was that chick
and you thought Ellie was a what you
know you know was not cool and Abby was
that chick and I think that's the issue
here because every issue I have degrades
alien every issue you didn't have that I
have that you don't have is because of
how they portrayed ad me and you like
Abby and I hate it and I can't say I
hated her understood where she was
coming from but I don't think I hate I
hate the person that has it all and
throws it away for nothing and ends up
with was with nothing
don't don't complain with your little
two fingers missing I mean maybe you're
some Wayne maybe they were foreshadowing
that she felt like maybe if she finished
this that it would help her mental state
because that's what she was having that
the PSD I'm so happy and she went to go
finish it and it was Joel at peace
playing his guitar because he what Joel
story was his story and his whole
motivation was to get this girl to the
fireflies and to save mankind and when
he found out that they were going to
kill her he made a distinct choice that
choice came back to kill him
but at the end of the day he was even
more tore up because he lied to Ellie
and he told Ellie that the Cure wasn't
real it was all a hoax and that her life
wouldn't amount to anything and Ellie
was willing to die for her life to
amount to something they had a problem
because of his lies and his deceit in
his treachery he dies because his lies
his deceit in his treachery
they don't get a chance to make it right
and there is where the story starts and
then you get to understand the psychosis
of a character who loses everything
Abby is the most tragic character in a
damn game because every twist and turn
she has a noose around her neck she hung
up and strung up someplace else always
never getting that prize every time the
prize is there
it's yanked from her and all she wants
to do is at the end is to stake live and
just leave and just leave
she doesn't want no more but she didn't
wanna fight le bouche at the end that
had it let Tommy talk her ass into
leaving and her girl told her come back
to bed how many times is your girl told
you to come back to bang yo asses in a
jail cell looking up like I should have
listened to my girl
look she's a douche do at the same time
you know obviously we don't know
everything about Abby growing up how
many times like you know she price she
had it seemed like she had it made there
too and she took all her friends to go
kill a man that you know if she knew
what would happen she knew that he would
he killed them to save Ellie
so do you real can you really attack a
Leaford Ellie for doing that but you
can't attack Abby for an attack Abby she
lost everything she lost offers he lost
all and she also she lost her love her
love she jumped off of that thing she
was scared to death on that um on that
uh the ferris wheel she was good at
death she jumped down there looking for
him she knew where he was she knew him
that was her love of her life she had to
watch the love of her life have somebody
else pregnant and she told her you know
she thought that she wasn't going with
him to Seattle
she said yeah I'm going but you ain't
I'm not going if you going I get that
you know I feel like when it comes to
stuff like that that's just gonna be up
for debate up for what about the Noora
Noora felt the same way they all felt
the same way after she did what she did
remember a lot of these dudes is former
flies that are not down with Isaac's
plan and Isaac you can see it is the
ultimate scumbag because Isaac does not
care for his people at all he didn't
even really try to act like he didn't
respect like and the way they acted like
Abby was one of their best fighters one
of their best people cool and like when
she said yo don't kill these people
there's just a woman and a child
Isaac should have respected that and at
least took him prisoner or something you
know what I'm saying he's like no no you
gonna move aside and we're gonna kill
them we gonna deal with you later that's
literally what he said like you know who
he was when he tortured their so-called
Messiah and made a martyr out of her and
he did it on purpose and he had glee
with it
I knew the level of individual that I
was dealing with where he can commit
atrocities and eat afterwards see this
is where okay after the JD stay we got
another super chair stitch with the
photo super chat Joe Joe died because
that beast beat him with a golf club
I am glad she lost everything yeah and
there goes meal you see you see when
when he was being beat to the floor you
thought it was a chance that he was
gonna get out of it he told was a chance
that somebody was gonna kick in the door
you thought there was a chance to
Jackson's
dude was gonna show up in full force and
stop this brutality he died finished
they went to his house and looked over
his cold things
I was so happy when he was finished when
he was done when his story was over
because his story overshadowed le story
because you always knew that he was
gonna come to her rescue and this is
what le had to stand on her own two feet
ten toes in the dirt he was gonna see
what she was made of and she went out on
her own and she got some help by Jesse
dead by Dina useless but she still went
out on her own and she learned that from
Joe
so without Joel's depth you will never
know how strong le truly was okay so you
know obviously you know those are
perspectives when it comes to these
particular characters now let's talk
about the game as a whole real quick you
know obviously we talked about the
pacing we talked about how they did the
overall game Oh game before you played
this game like I played it a couple of
days before the first one yes I played
it like two months okay did you remember
the feel of the game yes it was wasn't
it kind of robotic it was kind of crazy
if you think about it because it kind of
felt similar but not similar at the same
time yes you know I think that was their
intentions but you know as far as the
story let's let's write this game from
every ten this though I'm gonna give the
story a six out of ten I don't like this
okay let's talk from the sample might
come play a guitar at the end King I
wasn't feeling that oh did you wait did
you see how funny who was when you tried
to what it was going on I was like
something crazy and I was like yo Neil
is on one right here baby let's go to
gameplay gameplay the gameplay
outstanding I gotta give dad a ten
coming from the first game right so
we're gonna talk about the evolution
from the first game because we're gonna
compare it to the first game we're not
gonna pairing it to something else we're
gonna compare it to that the ace in the
genre which I consider Last of Us one
like one of the aces in that genre right
and for them to do that bottle toss that
I didn't think that they can get it off
and they showed it in the the vertical
slice when he was able to run grab the
bottle tossed about I mean it's a little
bit more clunky when it gets into actual
gameplay doing it but the gist of it is
completely there um con crafting weapons
the physics engine you can't understate
the physics engine alone because you can
able to bust windows out and take the
rope and do things not supposed to do
with it um I thought the foliage was
beautiful the the use of cover the use
of verticality in the game
the underwater elements of the game it
took the first game and it went so if
the first game to me was a seven or
eight it definitely bumped it all the
way up to it you gotta say a nine plus
or close to a 10 min out of ten um it's
just a little bit of clunkiness to it
like in the menus and stuff like that
but I have to say the gameplay was
top-notch I have to give it a nine to
ten out of ten it was it was definitely
some of the best gameplay I've played in
a long time yeah alright so obviously
you think me bring the graphics up that
is a 10 out of 10
well I would say I would have to get the
graphics at six because it was some one
clip that he said it was six is it Joe
um I felt that the use of a great
storyteller with the graphics and you
know not needing to be at a certain
higher fidelity working within your
parameters and giving you exactly what
they're able to give you from these
parameters whereas definitely fantastic
hold on one second I got to take this
phone call okay so why Kings taking this
phone call what we're gonna do is we're
about to end this so I see that we have
we have fifty likes so I'm gonna give a
question for every ten so we're going to
answer five questions real quick
obviously I can't answer every question
here so I'm gonna answer the good ones
that I think is actually going to be an
abuse I'm go I'm going to give them so
you guys go ahead put some questions in
there for me and King you don't have to
super chatham just yeah it's just you
know go ahead and do five of them real
quick before we head out of here but you
know one thing I want to say King is
regardless how people feel about this
game regardless how people feel about
this didn't even talk about the
transphobia stuff of the characters we
didn't we didn't delve I mean I came 100
percent prepared to talk about the whole
what do you want to talk about I mean we
had to see the the trauma that live had
to go through with being ostracized from
her community and being shunned and only
person I was in a corner was her sister
for her sister to die fired I have to
kill a mother then the only person that
she can depend on is Abby and Abby
understands that right okay so we talked
about it so we can move on now okay I'll
bring that up real quick so you want to
breathe I didn't know you want to talk
about that because this game is not
regular game it's it's okay I actually
really appreciated the scars because it
felt like a completely different world
yeah it was they didn't use technology
for the most part they built giant
skyscrapers they were even smarter in a
lot of aspects and then the wolf's water
so didn't they use military strategic
things and what the scar is
did was they thought they were given and
they used what they were giving me you
that the land gave them and isn't isn't
that exactly how a society would break
down you would get a military aspect you
would get a holistic aspect and you will
get a ravages those those those people
that was stealing people those uh what
was they called it was called the the
slitherers was this the slashes or
something like that
the one that actually caught a being
them at the end and had those people in
the prison camp picking cotton and all
this other stuff I can't yeah there was
like the slither is a snakes or
something something something weird and
those you your society rattler yeah they
will break down into those three
different type of types military
holistic and lawless and you saw those
different type of societies in full
effect and what they did to the people
now the people in the military zone had
a military aspect everything looked like
it was top-notch on the surface and
everybody believes that they're right
okay but there's flaws in every each and
every society and when they had a the
holistic aspect of it
they had them shaving their heads they
having them scarring their faces and
those people look completely weird to
the Wolves and the Wolves look
completely weird to them and nobody
agreed with the little slithering dudes
that was over there with what they were
doing cuz it was actually capturing
people and forcing them to work an
indented servitude um and then if they
tried to leave they killed them so I
love how he showed the underbelly of
humanity at the end instead of us all
banding together and becoming one Ying
and trying to figure out how to change
this and how to fix the world all we did
was just separate into little groups and
form our own ideologies and continue to
act as
what is it warring entities against each
other instead of attacking the problem
and that is society at a whole so I
think he encompassed that in the game
which was magnificent to me because at
this point in time everybody needs to
come together but they couldn't come
together even in the the sight of deadly
foe that was destroying humanity
it was absolutely nuts to see I have to
agree with you on a lot of aspects so
one of the biggest things that I just
really appreciated the atmosphere and
last was - I thought was it was I
wouldn't say one of a kind but it's some
of the best atmosphere we had in a long
time so you know we do have some
questions here key first off someone
wants to know do you think Abby was
attractive
I love Abby I love a muscled up chick so
let me do it I personally don't think
Abby was attractive but that's just me
Oh someone asked do you um do you think
there will be a part three it has to be
oh so you're gonna get at the later end
of the cycle of the PlayStation five
feels like they're just gonna make
something new and just stick to that or
do you think they might do what they did
to unchartered where they'll they'll
find something new make that game and
then do that loss hoorah with with Last
of Us and make lots of us three and into
always three big trilogies you gonna
have some DLC with I can see what
happens with Tommy in this stuff over
here you you want to know what happened
with Abby and the fireflies and plus you
want to know you want to Karaboudjan of
Ellie and the Cure you want to know what
happens if Ellie ever gets back to
Jacksonville and gets a chance to talk
to Dina and confronts that situation you
want to see what happens it's too many
ifs ands too much stuff because remember
she removed herself from that society so
it's it's a lot of things that they can
talk about you know as repercussions to
it remember nothing is as minor and it's
small any longer so
for those little things you'll be
looking those two those ties that you
know inside the last bus - that leans to
the ties of glass history so it's a
question what's the name of of the gym a
V worth - you said the gym had a pretty
crazy
you know what's crazy they had a gym in
that building they fell on to remember
you past that gym in the building that
they fell in the treadmill and stuff
like that if you have a question from
here on just put a question mark at the
end of it so it's easier for me to
figure out because we have two more and
I want to get some good ones
okay well it's do you know did they make
like oh people people come an extra
today man he's supposed to the last of
us three Revenge of Rat King son Rat
King was that big thing that you fought
in on as le that was crazy
okay someone wants to know will the last
of us to win game of the year they
better it better
what's a better game why does if hey
what infinite comes out in its list not
also you think there's zero chance halo
beats it in game of the year yo bro you
know you know I don't care what they do
a halo I'm not crying
well that's not true because I did shed
a tear when this girl was going crazy
and Master Chief said it kind of got me
a little bit of Master in Halo 4 when
Cortes was on that bridge and she say
div and she's like it's it's my turn to
save you yeah that did you that kind of
did to me too um I'm not gonna say I'm
listen the bar is set so high the bar is
set so high that I'm not gonna say halo
Infinite won't come in and do it
listen graphically it could blow it out
of the water it will it'll be a next
generation game um don't tell me is on
current generation stuff just be quiet
story-wise it could tie up a lot of
things that we want to see so it's funny
how
it's only bringing up halo against this
game there's gonna be other game is now
it is not really gonna be the Final
Fantasy so they can't a remake can't win
Game of the Year in my opinion it has
already had sauce McQueary talked about
that it already has sauce material all
they did was come and put a pretty coat
on it and it was pretty ugly before
you're gonna like this okay like this so
it asked how loud or your ps4 is when
you were playing this how loud was it my
I didn't it mine wasn't loud at all I
cleaned the vents because somebody told
me you've got a loud ps4 Pro one more
question guys one more question I clean
the vents on the side and in my dog
walked past it up now two more questions
so when I said that the lights went up
another ten so we have to ask two more
questions two more questions guys
someone said while I'm waiting for a
good question Halo Reach made me cry
noble six went out in a blaze of glory I
don't think I cried with halo halo reach
like I felt like he went out the way he
wanted to go out like cuz he could have
went on there and she said damn them
ain't dying in this place but like hehe
when they try to shoot that I think it
was a when they try to shoot the [ __ ]
that they were leaving in and I can't
remember which one is they have so many
ships these days that that's been
destroyed anything and he's like no you
go
I gotta stop that from I gotta get you
guys out of here I respected that man I
respected that all right so do you think
okay so someone said do you think it was
realistic that Tommy Dena and Ellie made
it back to Jackson after getting messed
up so they're pretty much asking what
you I see a lot of this game where you
know Tommy got shot in the back of the
head which we don't know the degree
could have got grazed I don't know and
he got hit with the bow that seemed to
do more permanent damage because the a
limp so they want to know how did he get
medical attention after he had those
traumas okay well to push the narrative
forward Tommy had to still be alive we
thought so I thought Tommy was dead I
did too because when he when they did it
I thought they were killing everybody
yeah I thought I thought Tommy was dead
after she did all that but you know live
live live again shout out to live for
saving them again um and Deena wasn't
really all that banged up she had this
to shoulder you know and they are
trained medics in combat all right so
you get access same question and hi
Ellie was able to show her body up after
she was hung upside down and stabbed
inside of her body you know on their
train film medics so these dudes have
combat training and I don't ask me I
thought tommy was dead I guess Tommy's
gonna be a DLC because remember Tommy
went out there well they've already came
out openly I was gonna bring that up
after you got your thoughts someone
asked it was Danny said what do you
think DLC for less was to look like they
already came out so there's not gonna be
any DLC for the like you know why it's
not gonna be any DLC for the Last of Us
cherry
Gotham is sent to be it's gonna be a DLC
for the Last of Us to remake so
technically there's not gonna be any DLC
for The Last of Us
- but it'd be DLC for the Last of Us to
remake on a play war behind the
PlayStation 5 I could see that they
could they potentially use six once
every game comes out it's gonna have one
of those all right so you know that we
definitely answer six questions any any
last thoughts in the game King I love it
you love it I mean I think it's a good
game King I think it's a solid game I
personally like Final Fantasy seven more
I think I enjoyed it I gave it I
personally said it was worth $60 I don't
give I don't give any scores on my
reviews but I did say if I did give it a
score like privately - people would be
an 8 out of 10 to me and if if any of
you know me like reviewing things and
eight is not something that you can get
from you very easily I usually give a
lot of games six or seven uh I say this
I say if you don't have a Playstation
and go buy a Playstation about a game
and that's the highest praise I'm gonna
give a game do you think that it's worth
getting a PlayStation so close to the PS
5 or should they wait for the PS 5
version I don't trust them
because I don't trust a backpack I don't
trust them do you see okay let's say
let's say doesn't have a backpack do you
honestly think they won't like rerelease
the game on the PS 5 I think they're
gonna do that but do you think people
should go out and buy this when they
could potentially get a like a 60 frame
version on the PS 5 I think right now if
you have a lack of entertainment going
on in your life you have a surplus of
cash you want to play a damn good game
you can do it if you can financially do
without breaking the bank I'm not
telling you to go rob a bank to go get
the PlayStation to do this and add a
third I'm telling you if you have extra
cash sitting around and you want to get
a Playstation or somebody has a
Playstation you just want to borrow the
PlayStation find your way over to a
Playstation and play this game now if
first party first up in third person
first story driven games aren't your
thing then just stay away from it but if
if story driven games is your thing you
owe it to yourself to try it even if
your Xbox head yeah I mean first of all
I don't understand that whole Xbox head
and PlayStation ID thing your gamer so
remove those shackles around your legs
because those invisible things would
take this gaming console stuff a little
too serious yeah so if you get a chance
to go play it if a friend has it you
know let me borrow it or whatever with
you if you have a ps4 there's no reason
you don't have this game it's it's good
it's really really good it's definitely
one of the best experiences you can have
on the ps4 and I do think it's worth the
money like King said I don't know if
it's worth picking up a ps4 night it's
worth owning a ps4 for but since we're
so close to next-gen I don't know if
it's worth buying one right now when you
could just wait for the PS 5 oh look at
the launch lineup maybe in my remake in
the launch lineup day to date you know
60 frames a second actual 4k and you get
that game I mean I would buy it again
you know for that I did it already I did
it with the PlayStation 3 in the last of
us the first one and I brought the for
the PlayStation 4 because they didn't
have no back a bad situation so um I
have no problem with it you know certain
games
and I will buy physical this time
because I brought a digital I really
don't trust something so I will want the
game yeah definitely I definitely don't
blame you on that
but anyway this was our spoiler cast on
the Last of Us part 2 featuring King
David and Lord addict you know
we we do this for the community you know
we're usually a little bit less loose
with the chat but you know because you
guys are so good to us week out weekend
you know we definitely wanted to give
back and plus King wanted to talk about
this game and I still didn't get a
chance to get all my bars off so I'm
gonna do another spoiler cast on this
game soon because I honestly don't think
it's you know it bothers the hell out of
me
that only four million you know dudes
went out gay and date and cop it bothers
the hell out of me
and maybe it's Financial Times or right
now so if that's a certain somebody
circumstance enough you know god bless I
understand but if it's not your
circumstance and it's over one hundred
and thirtysomething million out there
those those numbers is very terrible you
know and those the game needs to be
experienced the the genius of Neil
druckmann needs to be spread oh my god
no man how about you boy
I respect your genius it was a wonderful
script it was a great story and thank
you I appreciate it
there you go King King definitely
cosines the game you can always follow
King on Twitter with your people who say
Kings wrong all podcast Xbox game listen
to me alright so what can people who are
fine you man you got listen you can find
me on Twitter at a King David OTW and
you can actually go right there and say
King I don't believe you so I can bless
you and take you down with some memes
will me understood exactly what happened
when you come for the King I had to pull
out Beyonce
the bushes Yahoo oh and if you go to my
timeline you see what I'm talking about
that's my guy will me hood speaking of
that Saturday at 11:30 tattoo will be
going down you get a chance to check out
that tattoo if you're part of the realm
so I will tell you to make sure that you
like follow us subscribe and also become
a member hit that joint button at that
bottom or become a patreon member
because it's only going to be available
for patreon members and members of the
realm to see that video of me getting
back tattoo and grape in mind that this
is never going public it's always gonna
be members so if you want to see this
you about to join the realm or go on
patreon and if I find anyone recording
that video and putting that video put it
out of the realm as we deal with
integrity here people go in the back you
see that logo right here that logo on my
chest right here
where'd you go in the back huh where'd
you get that in the back
oh I brought it for my tee spring school
at a spring all right I'm glad to get
one of those put it on my back too all
right but you know this is definitely
been a good time we'll have to do more
of these III guess well we probably do
one for Halo I don't know yet it just
depends on what halo comes out so anyway
you know this is our Lord's podcast
definitely come watch every Sunday at 1
p.m. this week we're gonna have a great
guest I'm not gonna ruin it that's
that's that's that's called nito's job
definitely be looking out for that
information on Twitter on Friday to
Saturday but we're out of here peace
catch y'all later
I give them that call it and we're
bringing to you an exciting is like none
other
we'll be giving away an Xbox series X
that's right you heard me right
the brand new console launching from
Microsoft this year well this is how
you're Abe
to be part of that giveaway there's two
ways to get your name thrown in the head
for the raffle one become a member of
the realm
that's that joy button hit that joy
button you hit that joint button down at
the bottom and you can become a member
and also another way is by becoming a
patreon member so you can be part of the
realm as well now this is brought to you
by cat daddy fat stacks a member and
lord of the realm a very generous person
that's in our community and this
community is beautiful so remember you
can have one entry by hitting that joint
button and becoming a member of the
realm and also you can have another
entry by being a patreon now you said
king what if I'm a member of both well
your name gets thrown in the Hat two
times so please like follow us subscribe
join or become a patreon member or
become both and your name is in the Hat
to get that Xbox series X as to who did
their for you sweepstakes this is
wonderful this is something that I'm
sure that you will enjoy oh man have a